reference by presidential Michelle and
Musa live on the line following the
phone call video call I should say with
the other g7 leaders on the Kovich 19
outbreak after the intervention of both
presidents will take a couple of
questions within the room of course but
we know that a lot of news outlets are
following this press conference directly
and live and so we'll take a couple of
questions which I will get on my
whatsapp here and so we'll do both but
I'll first give the flow to the european
council president thank you thank you
for your presence let me start by
expressing our full support to all
health workers who are working day and
night to fight this crisis and let's be
clear we know that this process will be
difficult we know that it will take time
and we know that it will be very
essential to be united we had the
occasion today to have a phone
conference with the g7 countries and the
leadership of the United States it was
the occasion to express of strong
political will to address this crisis
together to coordinate to cooperate in
different fields for us the priority is
the health of our citizens and it's why
we have last week encouraged the member
states to work together in order to take
some measures in order to 2010 the
spread of the virus this is the first
priority how is it possible to take
concrete measures in order to contain
the spread of the virus the last days
with the Commission with the Member
States we have worked very hard in order
to make some concrete proposals in order
to develop a more European approach in
order to make more progress in the next
days in the next weeks
a celeries ron [ __ ] el nuevo on
purple a strong eye digital more travel
is you the proposition I found the
jelly-like is from the frontier it is
only contain
interior a different external pain
electronic age underdeveloped p suea
extremel more important life philosophy
electability home V Allah for read we
leave movement and somebody move nor
mrs. sir
a dollar Mentos I don't like syphilis no
the National is dibs on our Father ve as
Pope with guarantee Oh totally possible
until democracy interior guarantee with
a provision Modi so the leases that are
coming for the quality come to Nev lack
contamination Oh totally perceive no
system doesn't show La Plata difference
determine like capacity to do so
properly as we knew that all dolly rule
in all its moment even a student
essential point is the medical equipment
and it's important to continue what you
are trying to do in order to guarantee
the possibility for the member states to
have access to the medical equipment we
are working it on that with the member
states and will continue in the next
days all the efforts in order to to face
this other important challenge third
point we have announced last week that
we were working very hard in order to
guarantee more support for the
researchers in order to make more
progress and to be able to develop a
vaccine it was also the occasion during
the g7 port conference to to decide to
work more together in order to be able
as soon as possible to make concrete
progress which is also very important
alpha catenin pontiff a sunset with
mossy oniy iove salaam
mobilization further reduce laser bad
economy totally possible sum total mo
determining the president la comisión de
consejo para la cita mama affair to suit
ISA necessary to sukira
responsible for the cottage licit 100
totally percy before the default la
posición
desert were three special model put it
in the million
please I found a fair shot to lope with
mobile devices more I found a suit neo
totally possible activity economic evade
we oughtn't we perceive leaden our
deities Association also Mamata video
conference in Reno
demonstra destinos European revolutions
no Dupree possess a train Oh a very
different day tomorrow
avec la president allahu allah contract
remission reasonable jalapeno Ruby LMS
octave Allah addresses la mobilization
politic a factor appreciat determinate
to latest mo le so mangu two S's prima
donna disposal Poirot
equity deceit wala equity de family so
devoted effective a positive economic
actor to des entreprises la grande petit
mal Isetta citizens said mobilization
don't charge a set Despero you support
mobilization adorable Oh travel
reservoir a daughter Maricopa visual
applause multilateral
damage control disorder nous devons
little Aussie 2003 saviours Allah heed
her longer invitin difficile mezcla
compilations and conventional food at
assembly
so thoroughly good first resume solution
apple and a discipline deceit wanna
shock ritual and vigil more total hanya
respect Aleppo since underneath will
applaud at a national national also low
blow Latinos and tooth actor
response amplitude APIs contribute as
Ferran Soriano mr. hoppity's debate a
2008 release difícil de novo a fantasy
new granola decision and little more
personal nonsense here or in the novel
responsibility clarity to see an
important move along and received early
thank you very much so indeed we face a
global health crisis and this global
health crisis has a severe impact on
people but also has a severe impact on
our economies and today indeed in the g7
conference we were sending a very strong
message that by staying together by
working together and coordinating we are
able to weather this storm which is a
global storm without any question
coordination is of the utmost importance
you mentioned it and therefore we had
indeed several topics we were working on
first of all the fact that we will have
to take measures to limit and to slow
down the spread of the virus this is
important that our healthcare system is
able to deal with the amount of patients
that are severely ill and therefore it's
of utmost importance to take all these
measures member states are taking right
now to slow down social contacts to slow
down public life and therefore to slow
down the spread of the virus on the
other hand this poses a lot of question
on how to maintain the rapid flow of
goods and how to keep our economy agile
and vital and in this context we
informed today our g7 partners that we
propose to introduce a temporary
restriction on non-essential travel to
the European Union why that because we
think non-essential travel should be
reduced right now - in order to not to
spread the virus further be it within
the European Union or by leaving the
European Union but also to avoid
non-essential travels not to have more
potential strain on our healthcare
system of course there will be
exemptions for example for you citizens
coming back home for health care workers
like doctors and nurses but also
scientists working on the solution of
this
crisis we do see but also people
commuting on borders who are working on
both sides of the borders for example
there will be exemptions it is a
restriction that should be in place for
an initial period of 30 days and we have
been talking about that with the g7
partners second topic we must coordinate
the measures we take to avoid negative
impacts on our people our economies and
our supply chains this was a big topic
and is a big topic between the Member
States it is important to look at the
different measures how they are take
taken and I think of utmost importance
is that neighboring countries harmonize
their measures so that this is the same
strong message to the people that the
member states are conveying because here
this increases then the certainty for
people to know that it is yes difficult
at the moment being but it's for the
best of their health and for the moment
this is necessary third we need to
restore global economic confidence and
indeed it is time to support our
economies with determination that is
what we are doing with all the
appropriate instruments we have we
support the sectors that need it we
support our companies we support the
small and medium enterprises and above
all we support people we support them in
their jobs we support them with their
income losses so right now the focus is
on strengthening our economies and
investing whatever is necessary to have
the economy going on further as I
announced on Friday last week the
European Union has put in place an
ambitious framework and we will not
hesitate to take further action as the
situation evolves fourth and last point
indeed we need to boost research on
vaccines and therapies also on
Diagnostics it was interesting to hear
in the g7 debate that there is a strong
focus or strong support for sepi which
is an initiative we started together
although met those members of g7 we
started after Ebola so it's coming from
the lessons learned from Ebola a
platform of renown scientists this is
also a message of strong coordination
here to put a lot of emphasis on a
promising project on a platform that has
already proven that it is very effective
in this area and finally the
international response should be
broadened and therefore we agreed today
to also call upon g20 to accelerate work
so that our response is as effective as
possible
globally thank you well first take a
question of political yes David
presidents we see today the guidelines
from the Commission about internal
border controls that are being imposed
concerns where you have to remind Member
States to allow you citizens to travel
home that people who are sick should get
health care not be turned away at the
border that in fact goods and services
must be able to cross that has raised
questions in some people's minds about
whether the very core fundamentals the
four freedoms the core purposes of the
EU are in jeopardy because of this
corona crisis are you concerned about
the EU at that level of fundamentality I
understand that the Member States the
governments in the member states do
everything they can to protect their
people but indeed we have to be very
careful to find the right balance
between on one hand restricting the
social context and therefore the virus
to spread but on the other hand not to
hamper our single market because right
now we need a very well functioning
single market to deliver on the goods we
need and therefore we put out in our
guidelines that
we recommend to install so-called green
corridors fast lanes for the good
transport so that the traffic jams will
end and that we have a fast flow of
goods this is important for keeping up
the single market and keeping up our
economy okay next question please
hello Quentin is for The Washington Post
I do during your phone call did you
discuss with mr. Trump on what's
happening with the German company cubic
and on media report about the US wanted
to have exclusive access to this vaccine
cure or like I know mrs. Mandela and you
are discussing with security with this
company later on today so I was
wondering late did you talk with mr.
Trump about the issue and did he confirm
it like even if access we we expressed a
very strong political will we can see
that that is very important to work
together in order to to develop
therapies to develop vaccines we
mentioned a very concrete initiative a
very concrete proposal and during this
video transparency we felt a very strong
current political will in order to make
progress together also in this field
okay I have a couple of remote questions
by Jennifer ranking from The Guardian
answer Patricia Ann Sione
a question for both President Michele
and president from the line and has the
travel ban already been approved by the
member states or should the European
Council decide tomorrow and will this
apply to UK citizens we we have worked
together the last hours in order to
inform two different member states that
we were working together in order to
take some measures regarding the the
borders it was important first of all to
inform officially the g7 countries what
we did during this phone call we will
have tomorrow video transparent with the
27 member states and in the next hour we
will continue to inform to explain what
the permission
proposing because as you probably know
this proposal for the Commission has to
be agreed by each member states each
member state has the possibility to
implement what the Commission would
propose yeah we had indeed together
reach out over the weekend to the
majority of member states and there was
a strong support so officially tomorrow
we're gonna finalize that and your
question on the UK's citizens the UK
citizens are European citizens so of
course there are no restrictions for the
UK citizens to travel to the continent
have one last question from Jim Bronson
from the Financial Times for both
presidents are you confident that Member
States will sign off on the ban on
non-essential travel into the European
Union because it seems like a couple of
countries like Romania Baltic states
have been caught by surprise also have
the portion associate countries agreed
to this a question from the Financial
Times yeah I had the opportunity to talk
beforehand for example to Norway and for
example to Switzerland and I'm aware of
the fact that they already introduced
measures that are very close to that so
for them it was first of all very
positive to see that there will be no
changes for their citizens but that they
are included in this scheme we want to
put up thank you very much
following the you co-counsel tomorrow
we'll organize another press briefing
you
[Music]
you